[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 c'est le tour d'horizon
de l'actualité locale et régionale en 26
minutes tout de suite les titres de ce
mercredi 20 février c'est le cheval de
bataille du moment dans plusieurs
collèges du département la dotation
horaire attribuée aux établissements par
la direction académique professeurs et
parents d'élèves en dénoncent les
conséquences des mobilisations se tenait
à elancourt et au mesnil saint denis
l'association vient d'être lancée à
guyancourt trait d'union se fixe comme
objectif l'insertion professionnelle
dans les quartiers en difficulté un
premier projet pour aider à la création
d'entreprise est établi elle nous
recevons a dit mme ahmed président de la
structure
enfin c'est une oeuvre emblématique à
plaisir la statue du parc du château et
en restauration le nom de cet ensemble
du xviiie siècle et celui de son auteur
reste inconnu mais nous avons suivi une
étape de sa rénovation avec un sculpteur
autres invités en plateau alexandre
morlaix chargé de mission communication
au sein à des républicains des mines
c'est tout à l'heure dans ce journal
attention ces images peuvent choquer
celle de l'association l214 diffusé en
2017 montrant la maltraitance des
cochons au sein de l'abattoir guillard
en deux ou dans et demain une audience
est prévue au tribunal de police de
versailles comparaîtront le directeur
trois salariés du site et un agent des
services vétérinaires un procès qui
devait initialement se dérouler en
janvier mais qui avait été reporté pour
vice de forme
suite à sa plainte plus de 60
infractions ont été retenus par le
procureur d'après l214
les enseignants sont nommés sont
nombreux à se réunir en ce moment dans
le département hier soir ils étaient
rassemblés devant le collège de la joie
et l'encours mobilisation ce matin
également devant le collège philippe de
champaigne au mesnil saint denis le
motif de la contestation c'est la
diminution est du nombre d'heures
attribuées aux établissements ainsi que
les conséquences engendrées les
précisions de manon barral d'eau et de
marylène yapi chinois ils veulent se
faire entendre professeur représentant
parents et élus protestent contre la
dotation horaire des établissements
attribué à la rentrée prochaine
nous sommes aujourd'hui devant ce
collège philippe de champaigne puisque
nous avons reçu il ya une semaine voire
dix jours la dotation horaire globale
pour la mise en place de la rentrée 2010
9 et il se trouve qu'elle n'est pas du
tout en adéquation avec les effectifs
prévus l'année prochaine pour la rentrée
de septembre il est prévu des classes de
30 élèves du jamais vu pour ce collège
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à 24 25
élèves par classe et on a un collège
atypique qui est sur deux communes qui
ont deux profils différents sur le
ministre n'est la verrière avec des
parcours scolaires différents et être à
30 par classe pour eux c'est c'est pas
possible pour alerter sur ses futures
conditions ils arrêtaient les
automobilistes en plus des classes
surchargées les accompagnements
éducatifs sont aussi menacés on craint
également la perte des différents
projets des différents dispositifs qui
nous permettent de faire davantage de
différenciation pédagogique notamment
sur des demi groupes ou sur des projets
science des projets autour du français
des projets interdisciplinaires que l'on
risque de perdre pour l'an prochain
dès hier soir c'est au collège de l'âge
yohaï l'encours que parents et
professeurs se rassembler soucieux
également de la qualité de
l'enseignement dispensé aux enfants on
va essayer aussi de de sensibiliser
davantage les parents qu'ils se rendent
compte que des 30 élèves par classe ça
ne permet pas une différenciation et ça
ne permet pas d'amener les élèves à la
réussite il faut que les parents aussi
en soit conscient ce sont leurs enfants
moi ma fille en 6e donc
pour le moment je sens pas enfin je vois
pas trouvé un intérêt pour elle mais je
sais qu'à moyen terme va être concerné
par les deux suppressions de classes
j'ai pas forcément envie qu que son son
enseignement soit dégradée un mouvement
qui continuera dans la tente d'un rendez
vous avec elle la direction académique
des yvelines eux aussi devaient se
rassembler ce matin les facteurs de
magny les hameaux ont finalement annulé
leur mobilisation ils ont obtenu des
engagements de la part de la direction
de la poste la cgt fo a pété appelaient
à la grève contre des projets envisagés
par le groupe le transfert de 80 % de
l'activité colis à bois d'arcy et la
réorganisation du centre de distribution
des courriers quatre postes étaient
menacés
elle est facteur reste tout de même
vigilants écouter leur réaction au micro
de manon varaldo la réaction elle est
positif puisque nous avons réussi à
faire fléchir la direction sans même
faire un jour de grève ce qui est
vraiment inattendu pour nous et mais
comme la plupart des facteurs nous
sommes encore méfiants puisque il le
prépare une nouvelle réorganisation et
nous nous attendons à peut-être d'autres
attaques de sous d'autres formes comme
la pause méridienne ou où les îlots et
peut-être d'autres attaques donc nous
restons méfiants moi en tant que délégué
syndical je vais suivre de très près la
prochaine organisation et nous vous en
parlions la semaine dernière l'usiné psa
de poissy produira bien le dernier v
véhicules électriques du groupe
confirmation du président à carlos
tavares un véhicule opel dont la
fabrication démarrera en 2021 sur le
site de 3000 salariés est dans un
communiqué le syndicat majoritaire fo
salle une excellente nouvelle pour les
employés qui assurent la pérennité du
site c'est le fruit d'un travail
d'équipé part réagi de son côté le maire
de poissy karl olive avec moi en plateau
alexandre morlaix bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes chargé de mission pour la
coordination de la communication au sein
des républicains à des événements on va
parler de vos missions dans un instant
alors vous êtes en entrée au sein de
l'équipe de pierre bédier suite à son
élection à la tête de la fédération en
octobre dernier pierre betty qui avait
promis lors de son élection le
rassemblement au sein de la fédération
en accordant notamment des postes de
vice-président à alexandra dublanche
outman nasri qui étaient ses adversaires
lors de la quand
est-ce que quatre mois après cette
élection est ce que le rassemblement ait
bien effectif au sein de cette
fédération où ils rassemblement est
effectif
aux côtés d'alexandra et d'autres
manient aussi des chargés de mission il
ya nathalie jacques mais qui est une
adjointe à bougival il ya également des
fans et marquait donc il y as any size
des marques est donc il ya déjà un
certain nombre de personnes qui se sont
rassemblées lors de nos deux bureaux
départementaux on s'est tous réunis
la quasi totalité des membres étaient
présents il ya aussi un projet qui est
sous l'égide d'alexandra du blanche qui
est lancée donc une douzaine de
thématiques sur lesquelles des référents
ont été nommés et sous ces référents il
ya une quinzaine voire une vingtaine de
personnes qui aujourd'hui travaillent
sur des études documentaires qui seront
présentés lors de notre prochain bureau
départemental au mois de mars car le 26
mars sera une présentation de ces
éléments là qui seront disponibles aux
cessions de sites internet et sur
différents médias sociaux qu'on vient de
lancer dans l'autre maître mot à côté du
rassemblement c'était la reconstruction
vous êtes vous chargé de mission pour la
communication au sein de cette
fédération les républicains est ce que
la reconstruction de cette fédération ça
passe aussi justement par la
communication oui c'est un des piliers
essentiels parce que
on avait pris un petit peu de retard on
avait pas de site internet moi j'avais
été à l'époque au sein de l'ump
l'un des fondateurs du site internet de
l'ump de 2003 à 2007 le site a disparu
depuis 2007 à 2019
on va dire la famille des républicains
qui est orphelin de sites internet c'est
un veau ou premier votation s'il n'est
pas des émissions c6 est de recréer ce
site internet de faire vivre
finalement toutes les informations qui
sont disponibles sur twitter sur
facebook auquel certains de nos
adhérents ou sympathisants n'ont pas
accès puisque ces réseaux sociaux sont
des réseaux sociaux qui sont faits on va
dire par like part il faut vraiment
faire partie de ce domaine là beaucoup
de gens sont en dehors de ski et
tablettes réseaux sociaux smartphones
n'ont pas forcément l'habitude d'aller
là dessus et le site internet permettait
à cette partie de la population qui
n'avaient pas accès à ces outils à ces
médias sociaux bat être aussi bien
informés que les autres donc l'ensemble
des informations s'entrecoupent entre
réseaux sociaux les sites internet comme
ça chacun son degré d'information donc
des outils mis en place avec ce site
internet notamment sur les prochaines
échéances électorales il ya forcément
aussi un rôle à jouer les européennes
qui sont programmés le 26 mai prochain
sur la communication quel est votre
relais ce que c'est par exemple de
parler de ces élections qui sont peu ou
en tout cas mal connu par par les
yvelinois par les français en général
voir toute une tout un ensemble
d'opérations de communication qui vont
être débattues lors de notre prochaine
de notre prochain bureau départemental
on va avoir un certain nombre de
opérations de tractage
on va avoir aussi d un certain nombre de
débats qui vont avoir lieu dans
différentes communes
on va être derrière notre candidat
françois xavier bellamy toute la
fédération est vraiment réunies derrière
ce candidat là on est souvent quand on
communique sur sur sa candidature qui a
suscité en tout cas quelques débats au
sein au sein des républicains notamment
autour de avec gérard larcher valérie
pécresse matane a toujours eu quoi qu'il
arrive aux républicains dans cette
famille on a toujours eu de nombreux
courants et de toujours eu à chaque fois
des kiev une candidature annoncée soit
disant on va dire des personnes qui sont
plus ou moins
d'accord avec tel ou tel candidat là on
est sur un triumvirat on a pas que
françois-xavier bella nous il en est
aussi agnès evren et puis on a aussi
monsieur daujan donc on a ces trois
personnalités là qui forment un bon
triumvirat chacun sur cette thématique
la sécurité toute la partie défense des
entreprises donc j'ai à dire aujourd'hui
voilà tout le monde est d'accord pour
défendre le programme des républicains
le programme des européennes
derrière ces trois personnes voilà donc
pour nous c'est à dire déjà les outils
numériques vont nous permettre
d'apporter de l'information à ceux qui
ne peuvent pas se rendre aux différents
débats aux différents meetings et puis
derrière aussi cessé d'informer les gens
parce que c'est vrai que souvent comme
on le dit on est mal informée très peu
de médias aussi nous laisse aujourd'hui
aux républicains la possibilité de nous
exprimer sur le programme c'est vrai
qu'il ya une sorte de deux grands points
sur xavier françois xavier bellamy sur
ce qu'il a pu être avant c'est pas la
question aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'il
représente le programme des républicains
ce qu'il veut faire pour notre famille
politique et donc j'allais dire tout ce
qui touche à ce qu'il a pu faire avant
c'est le passé aujourd'hui on est sur le
présent on a envie de gagner ces
élections européennes on a envie d'aller
de l'avant on a constitué un véritable
programme un véritable outil de
autour des entreprises autour de la
sécurité autour de certaines thématiques
très importante
je pense qu'aujourd'hui voilà on doit
tous se focaliser sur cet objectif là
qui est de remporter ces élections et
c'est grâce à la communication grâce à
notre présence sur les médias qu'on
arrivera à se faire entendre sur cette
candidature par le biais de ses
différents aux outils de communication
merci alexandre morlette d'être passé
sur ce plateau chargé de mission
coordination de la communication au sein
des républicains des yvelines en dix
minutes 10 secondes dans dieudonné a
rajouté une information c'est que le
jeudi 8 mars à 19h30 à plaisir nous
aurons l'occasion de recevoir bruno
retailleau qui viendra pour un grand
meeting départemental comme une
personnalité puisque c'est aussi le
présent du groupe et l'air au sénat et
donc c'est une personnalité qui est très
importante et qui sera là aussi pour
défendre nos intérêts aux élections
européennes l'information est passée
merci à vous en politique toujours les
militants debout la france engagés eux
aussi dans la campagne des européennes
hier la caravane du parti en tour de
france actuellement depuis janvier est
passé par les yvelines des étapes à
poissy versailles rambouillet pour
rencontrer les habitants
autre sujet non pas de la politique mais
la statue du parc du château de plaisir
qui se dévoile petit à petit dans le
cadre de la réhabilitation du parc la
municipalité a décidé de lui offrir une
seconde jeunesse reportage au plus près
de sa restauration avec marylène yapi
chinon pour accompagner sa concentration
autour des quatre éléments
depuis deux semaines dédiées matar
constituent les parties manquantes de
cette mystérieuse statut ils sont
arrivés un peu denses et à la à
l'atelier donc on a vraiment un état
sanitaire qui est vraiment très dégradée
avec des parties manquantes sur les les
jeunes ou les jambes
les têtes sur la partie haute le
sculpteur a tout de suite était surpris
par la qualité de l'oeuvre des détails
soignés et un style propre 18e qui n'est
pas sans rappeler les sculptures du
château de versailles
cette torsion qui tourne c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
une magnifique sculpture son nom reste
tout aussi inconnu que celui de son
auteur
elles représentent les quatre éléments
l'eau la terre le feu et l'air
ce sont les deux personnages qui ont les
ailes ceux du bas n'ont pas d'elle donc
là on me tend le bras en l'air de façon
à atteindre au l'air pour redonner la
beauté de ces détails à la statue dédiée
matar commence par créer une forme en
terre pour ensuite faire un moulage en
plâtre
une fois ce moulage parfait il sera
copié en pierre est posée sur la statue
tout ça ça n'existait pas on essaye
d'intégrer vraiment notre travail ou
patrimoine passé sans essayer de
d'inventer des choses on essaie vraiment
de respecter au maximum la sculpture
une fois terminée cette statue des
quatre éléments se retrouvera ici son
socle est déjà prêt à l'accueillir une
touche finale à la réhabilitation du
parc du château
nous sommes très fiers d'avoir une
oeuvre comme celle là dans le parc du
château
puisque ça ne fait que compléter
l'ensemble de ce que nous avons voulu
faire depuis de nombreuses années
château et statues se feront face deux
vieux amis qui retrouveront chacun leur
tour les traits de leur jeunesse
cette association guyancourt toise a été
lancé tout récemment trait d'union se
fixe comme objectif l'insertion
professionnelle dans les quartiers en
difficulté pour en parler son président
avec nous en plateau a dit mme ahmed
bonfort incendie alors on va parler
notamment de votre premier projet ouvre
ton biz pour aider les créateurs
d'entreprises déjà plus généralement sur
l'association pourquoi la lentille est
ce qu'il y avait un vrai besoin pour les
quartiers de la ville de guyancourt
effectivement nous avons pensé qu'il y
avait un besoin spécifique sur les
quartiers dits prioritaires ou 10
politique de la ville pas seulement
fourni en cours mais plus largement sur
saint quentin en yvelines
et puis j'ai une terre très contrastée
nous avons vu que c'était à la fois très
dynamique avec une terre d'innovation
technologique avec énormément
d'entreprises présentent un bassin
d'emploi qui le deuxième d'ile-de-france
145 mille emplois effectivement
l'enlever de la bouche et en même temps
il y a des quartiers une demi douzaine
de quartiers prioritaires qui sont
relégués où les taux de chômage sont
multipliées par 2 2 et demi ou taux de
pauvreté multiplié par deux et demi où
se concentrent les problèmes ou les
dispositifs classiques ne fonctionnent
plus donc nous sommes quatre citoyens
engagés qui avons envie de passer à
l'action avec ce constat justement
quelles sont les missions du coup de
trait d'union
alors la première mission va être un
projet qui s'appelle ouvres ton biz donc
favoriser l'entrepreneuriat social au
sein de ces quartiers là avec tout un
programme d'accompagnement avec des
professionnels
de notre réseau des chefs d'entreprises
globalement des consultants une banque
plusieurs types d'acteurs qui vont nous
aider de la création au développement
jusqu'à une année ou deux d'existence de
l'entreprise et donc nous souhaitons
être au plus près du terrain
alors vous le disiez c'est un territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines où
l'entreprise a une place particulière
seize mille entreprises sur ce
territoire c'est aussi plus propice du
coup pour développer ce genre d'action /
sur l'insertion professionnelle
effectivement c'est très propice je
crois que nous avons pas encore bien
communiqué que nous avons déjà une
dizaine de dossiers qui sont déjà
arrivés à l'étude
donc nous avons un calendrier de
recrutement des dossiers entre mars et
juin nous espérons si on travaille
actuellement monter un événement en juin
pour pouvoir collecter toutes les
demandes et ensuite nous serons en
capacité à partir de septembre 2019 de
suivre une dizaine de dossiers
nous avons quatre intervenants qui
pourront suivre ces dix dossiers sur 12
mois minimum voire quatre 24 mois pardon
et donc
oui le bassin est propice je pense qu'on
n'aura pas de mal à trouver ses dix
dossiers alors vous êtes vous même issu
d'un quartier défavorisé à toulouse mais
vous êtes aujourd'hui consultant
financier c'est important pour vous de
transmettre aussi cette expérience
jamais senti le besoin surtout avec le
contexte actuel de crise sociale et
gilet jaune et puis tout ce contexte là
m'a poussé à me dire qu'il faut passer à
l'action
on peut pas tout attendre du politique
on peut pas tout attendre des pouvoirs
publics et je pense que chacun de
prendre ses responsabilités et nous
avons senti que c'était le moment et
qu'il fallait le faire
les doux nom de cette association trait
d'union finalement faire le lien entre
l'expérience s'est activement et ses
besoins
effectivement vous évoquez mon origine
sociale effectivement je suis issu d'un
quartier populaire mais j'ai eu la
chance par par le système scolaire
français de progresser passait
différents échelons
j'ai fait dix en finance de marché chez
euronext et ensuite je passais dans le
monde du consultant qu'ensuite en
finance de marché en finance
d'entreprise et donc au gré de cette
expérience j'ai pu croiser énormément de
personnes et réseau s'est constitué avec
ses 20 ans la et donc je me suis dit à
un moment donné à des gens qui sont dans
les quartiers qui n'ont pas ce réseau là
et je veux être ce trait d'union entre
des professionnels les institutions
publiques
le monde plus globalement et ces gens là
qui sont dans ces quartiers et qu'ils
n'ont pas eu la chance de se constituer
son réseau la part qu aujourd'hui sur ce
thème de la création d'entreprise quels
sont les freins à votre avis pour pour
ces personnes issues des quartiers
l'accès au financement principalement
donc quand ils sont nés aux filles qui
savent pas monter un business plan et ça
sera monté un plan de financement
ils pensent que c'est pas possible des
fois il ya des projets qui se bloquent
pour 5 10 mille euros qui ne se font pas
et je pense que c'est beau c'est la
petits qui peuvent devenir vos par la
suite on doit pouvoir les accompagner et
éviter que ils passent les mailles des
dispositifs actuels il ya des
dispositifs aujourd'hui mais qui
répondent pas forcément à leurs besoins
donc on va être ce rouage ce petit trait
d'union pour réussir à ramener tout le
monde
dans le chemin du travail dans
l'entreprise
vous évoquez ce projet ouvre ton biz
premier projet mise en place par
l'association sait qui est concerné par
ce projet ce que c'est seulement les
jeunes ça s'adresse à toutes les
personnes générique jane louis englobe
beaucoup de choses jeanne entreprendre
votre honneur donc ça peut être ça peut
être des jeunes entrepreneurs âgés à
j'ai effectivement donc une personne qui
a 50 ans et qui est bloquée qui n'y
arrivent pas une reconversion
professionnelle et qui voudraient
pouvoir ouvrir son entreprise est le
bienvenu le terme jeune et plutôt dédié
aux jeunes entrepreneurs et non pas aux
jeunes le terme générique qu'on connaît
et comment on fait justement pour se
faire accompagner vous en disiez de mots
tout à l'heure on va mettre des process
de recrutement où on pourra nous
présenter les différents projets il y
aura un collège de 4 5 personnes
constituée principalement de chefs
d'entreprises qui vont étudier les
différents dossiers
il y aura des entretiens individuels et
sous la base de la détermination du
sérieux donc sélectionneront des
dossiers si nous avons beaucoup plus que
10 on en sélectionnera dix sur la base
de ces critères là donc toutes les
informations bien sûr sur la page
facebook qui s'est affiché une dernière
question est ce que c'est un projet qui
intéresse en tout cas auprès des
entreprises d'éventuels partenaires a
effectivement nous avons déjà trois
quatre partenaires qui sont issus de mon
réseau direct qui nous ont dit banco qui
nous soutiennent ils peuvent nous
fournir
des salles peuvent nous fournir des
moyens je sais pas si je peux les citer
et 20 secondes on avait secondes donc à
cléo groupe principalement qui nous
soutient il ya aussi une association
très forte qui s'appelle l'ecti qui nous
soutient et voilà principalement je
vendais secondes
voilà les deux principaux partenaires
mais il y en a d'autres qui vont en
vouloir parce que je sais pas si tu es
donc qui m'excuse par avance dans ce cas
toutes les informations encore une fois
je le rappelle sur la page facebook de
l'association merci merci à 10 miles est
dépassée sur ce plateau président de
cette association un trait d'union
mercredi jour de sortie au cinéma jour
de notre petit tour également dans les
salles du territoire ce soir
présentation du programme au ciné cet
élan course et au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude cette semaine au ciné
c'est une programmation la plus
éclectique possible en tout cas on
essaye donc plein de films à l'affiché
vacances scolaires obligent
je vous donne les titres rapidement
alita all inclusive une intime
conviction excellent à voir avec olivier
gourmet dans la peau de eric dupond
moretti
l'ordre des médecins la dernière folie
de claire darling
catherine deneuve doyen de rap se dit
qu'on a repris je le succès qui ne se
dément pas de ce film rave 2.0 pour les
enfants minuscule 2 et la chasse à
l'ours et je voulais surtout insisté sur
le festival ciné junior qui a lieu dans
nos salles pendant toute la durée du
mois de février même jusqu'à début mars
donc deux événements à vous proposer
cette semaine pour les enfants
ainsi défilent ou avec un court-métrage
fin films de court métrage capelle drôle
de planète dimanche matin à 10h30 et
surtout venez participer mardi prochain
à 16h 30 à l'atelier incrustation
incrustation pardon on vous expliquera
comment on fait des intrus stration dans
les films à partir de fonds vers vous
avez déjà dû voir ça dans des
documentaires et c'est donc un
spécialiste de l'incrustation viendra
vous parler de cette technique d'effets
spéciaux au cinéma dans nos salles donc
mardi prochain
16h30 aussi 17 dans le cadre du festival
si les juniors
[Musique]
il s'en consomme en moyenne 30 litres
par an et par habitant le sujet qui va
suivre devrait intéresser les amateurs
de bière un bar spécialisés elle vient
d'ouvrir dans le centre-ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux plus de 150
références y sont proposés michael mais
d'euros derrière ces portes se cache le
paradis des consommateurs de bière un
bar dédié en grande partie à la boisson
alcoolisée s'est ouvert le 16 janvier
dernier dans le centre-ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux le lieu est géré
par ludovic constantin amateurs de cet
alcool depuis ses 18 ans c'est vraiment
le domaine que je connais le mieux que
je peux expliquer aux clients même si je
propose du vin et des alcools
c'est vraiment ce que je préfère tout
simplement le bar propose plus de 150
références de bière et notamment des
spécialités françaises deux premiers
sont que des bières locales de vraiment
d'île de france et après les deux autres
sont des bières aussi
neuf ans de partout par exemple ici
c'est des bières du nord
ici des bières normande est ici des
bières de haute-savoie la bière ne coule
pas encore à flot mais la recette
commence à payer chaque jour le barreau
soit une quinzaine de clients dans ses
80 m² cas sympa c'est parfois que je
viens et ouais sympa l'ambiance est
agréable
j'aime bien la bière maintenant je vis
dans le nord à lille donc au général
vierge en bois c'est vraiment écolo
franchement c'est super d'avoir un bar à
bière dans nos voisins c'est pas grand
chose à part ça c'est sympa la bière est
bonne n'est-ce pas trop cher il vous
faudra débourser en moyenne 2 euros 80
pour un demi-litre et 5 euros pour une
bouteille de 33 centilitres et si les
clients ne veulent pas rester accoudé au
comptoir ils peuvent également acheter
des bières à emporter
et puis le 17e salon du vin et de la
gastronomie s'est tenu le week-end
dernier un rendez vous annuel au manège
royal de saint germain en laye organisé
par le lion's club local l'objectif
récolter des fonds pour des oeuvres
caritatives retour avec patrick jacques
de dixmude et nicolas landry qu'il soit
rouge blanc ou rosé qui viennent de boer
green d'alsace ou de provence tous les
vignobles français sont représentés au
salon du vin et de la gastronomie de
saint germain en laye c'est une première
participation pour pascal pieds noirs
venus de la vallée du rhône qu'on essaye
de faire des vagues des vins
rouge et blanc un petit peu de rose et
sur ses méridionaux avec de la fraîcheur
puisque nous sommes situé à 500 mètres
d'altitude
pratiquement sur les contreforts alpins
pour accompagner la dégustation viticole
charcuterie fromage et gâteau des quatre
coins de l'hexagone sont à disposition
au bon plaisir des visiteurs
on a dû l'oms au delà copains on a aussi
des saucissons du jambon ça passe par le
cochon noir est aussi bien du sanglier
donc c'est des produits qui sont quand
même assez à ses fins et des produits
qui sont un peu poivrez mais ça reste
très léger très subtil j'ai un peu la
diversité des produits
bon on pourrait encore avoir peut-être
un peu plus d'artisans
culinaire un peu peut-être un peu moins
de boissons mais ils sont tous charmant
on passe un bon moment voir on n'a plus
besoin de déjeuner quand on rentre chez
soi c'est une taille réduite donc il ya
un bien aussi qui ait pas trop de monde
parce qu'on a le temps de discuter avec
les producteurs
cette 17e édition compte 42 exposants
invités par le lion's club de saint
germain en laye objectif récolter des
fonds pour des actions humanitaires
comme l'accompagnement de personnes
atteintes d'autisme ou d'alzheimer
il y a également des plantations
d'arbres au sénégal en reversant 60
minutes ce qui permet de faire vivre des
familles de construire des écoles nous
en avons plus de 30 entre 2000 et 2500
visiteurs sont venus durant le week end
l'association ne souhaite pas
communiquer la somme des fonds récoltés
et tous ses produits à consommer bien
sûr avec modération c'est la fin du set
8 journal dans un instant nouveau numéro
du 7-8 débat le thème gens du voyage
comment cohabiter dans les yvelines
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]